heute geht es um zwei Themen zum einen
und die Frage was kann unter der
pflichtverstehen und ganz eng damit
zusammenhängt um die Frage was kann
unter der Achtung besteht ich will ein
paar zentrale Zitate Vorlesen
präsentieren anhand deren wir dann diese
zwei Begriffe den Begriff der Pflicht
und den Begriff der Achtung genauer
analysieren
ansagt um aber den Begriff eines an sich
selbst hoch zu schätzenden und ohne
weitere Absicht guten Willens so wie er
schon dem natürlichen gesunden Verstande
beiwohnen und nicht sowohl gelehrt als
wie man nur aufgeklärt zu werden bedarf
diesen Begriff den der Schätzung des
ganzen Werts unsere Handlungen immer
oben ansteht und die Bedingungen alles
übrigens ausmacht zu entwickeln wollen
wir den Begriff der Pflicht vor uns
nehmen denen eines guten Willens und
zwar unter gewissen subjektiven
Einschränkung und Hindernissen enthält
die aber weit gefehlt dass sie ihn
verstecken und unkenntlich machen
sollten in vielmehr durch abstechung
Heben und desto heller hervorschein
lassen das ist wieder ein sehr langes
Zitat aber es ist sehr sehr zentral weil
hier der Begriff des guten Willens den
wir in einer heurigen Sitzung diskutiert
haben ich mache oben rechts den Link
dazu hinein weil ich kann hier den
Begriff des guten Willens durch den
Begriff der Pflicht genauer bestimmen
man sagt auch gemeinhin das kann es
Ethik eine Pflicht Ethik ist oder eine
deontologische Ethik das heißt die Ethik
konzentriert sich auf das Prinzip
unseres Wollens und das Prinzip unseres
wollen es ist ein Gesetz und nicht nur
eine Neigung oder die Reflexion auf die
handlungs Folgen das wäre dann der
Utilitarismus oder konsequenzialismus
und auch da mache ich oben rechts ein
Link hinein in diesem Video
dann zeigt jetzt dass wir den Begriff
ist natürlichen Verstandes ernst nehmen
müssen und dass wir wenn wir unsere
alltäglichen Handlungen analysieren dann
stellen wir fest dass wir einen guten
Willen durchaus aufklären können dass
diese gute Wille aber nicht immer rein
zu Tage tritt hatte den guten Willen mit
einem Diamanten verglichen im Edelstein
und die Konsequenzen der Handlung hatte
er verglichen mit der bloßen Einfassung
das Edelsteins das heißt der gute Wille
der ist immer ein bisschen nach Kant
gehindert wir handeln nicht immer schon
gut unser Wille hat Hindernisse und
diese Hindernisse erkannt sind unsere
Neigungen unsere subjektiven Interessen
die halten uns davon ab einen guten
Willen nach dem Pflicht Gesetz
zu entwickeln
ja das erkannt jetzt zu dem Begriff der
Pflicht und jetzt wollen wir ein
bisschen weiter gehen jetzt bringt er
die Unterscheidung zwischen pflichtgemäß
und aus Pflicht also eine ganz wichtige
Unterscheidung die bedeutet folgendes
ein Kaufmann sagte hier der gibt das
korrekte Wechselgeld heraus oder der
betrügt seine Kundin und Kunden nicht
das kann man sich fragen warum macht das
der Kaufmann oder die Kauffrau und kann
sagt eine Neigung zu den Käufern hat er
wahrscheinlich nicht das machte nicht
aus Liebe
und er macht vielleicht oder
wahrscheinlich auch nicht immer nur weil
er ehrlich sein möchte also nicht aus
moralischen Gründen er macht es weil es
sein Vorteil erfordern und genau diese
Einstellung die der Kaufmann hier hat so
sagt es jedenfalls kann das ist die
Handlung aus Pflicht eben nicht sondern
es ist die Handlung die nur pflichtgemäß
ist legal der Kaufmann hält sich an die
Gesetze aber die Motivation die dahinter
steht die muss nicht moralisch sein das
kann er auch nur deswegen machen zum
Beispiel weil er befürchte dass wenn er
unehrlich ist dass der Betrug aufliegt
und sein ganzes Geschäft pleite geht das
heißt man kann ihm nicht unbedingt
unterstellen dass er das aus Pflicht
macht er macht es nur nicht gemäß
das ist wichtig Unterscheidung
pflichtgemäßes handeln und Handeln aus
Pflicht aus Pflicht bedeutet weil wir
die Sitten Gebote des Sittengesetz ganz
ernst nehmen also eine inneren
Einstellung und zwar aus der Einstellung
der Achtung
ja ein weiteres Zitat was sehr Vokativ
ist ist Kant überlegt sich ein Gedanken
Beispiel wo jemand den Geschmack am
Leben gänzlich verloren hat lebensmüde
ist und ganz sagt ein solcher Mensch der
dennoch aus Pflicht sein Leben erhält
sich nicht tötet der nur ein solcher
Mensch der selbst wenn er eigentlich
lebensmüde ist und dennoch
aus Pflicht sein Leben erhält nur der
hat eine wirklich moralischen Maxime
maximal müssen wir auch noch genau
erklären maximal bedeutet so viel wie
ein subjektiv verhandlungsgrundsatz nur
diese subjektiven Handlungsgrundsätze
können wir nach Kanten moralisch
bewerten dahin gehen ob sie pflichtgemäß
oder aus Pflicht sind
provokatives sind alles Zitat dass ich
nicht vorenthalten möchte und deshalb
kann aber obwohl wir die Pflicht haben
unser Leben zu erhalten selbst dann wenn
wir sehr krank sind zum Beispiel gesagt
kann soll mir nicht nur Leiden das wäre
nämlich auch nicht gut weil wir haben
auch eine zumindest indirekte Pflicht
unsere Glückseligkeit zu sichern
wenn wir nämlich unzufrieden wären mit
unserem Leben dann sagt kann würden wir
auch weniger geneigt sein moralisch
zeigen das heißt die Glückseligkeit das
angenehme Leben ist ein Mittel zum Zweck
zu Beförderung der Pflichten deswegen
ist es zumindest indirekt mittelbar eine
Pflicht glückselig zu sein aber
glückseligkeit ist nicht die höchste
Motivation nicht das höchste Prinzip
unseres Wollens und Handelns weil das
wäre dann eine eu-darmonistische Ethik
und von der grenzt sich krank strikt ab
jetzt hat er ein ganz zentrales Zitat er
sagt um die Pflicht genauer zu bestimmen
Pflicht ist die Notwendigkeit einer
Handlung aus Achtung fürs Gesetz es ist
ganz interessant
was heißt es
Neigung müssen wir von Achtung
unterscheiden
Achtung ist etwas was
mit dem Gefühl Erhabenheit ganz eng
zusammenhängt und kann sagt das Achtung
immer dem 7 Gesetz gilt also
letztendlich dem Gedanken der Pflicht
und das die Achtung wenn Sie diesen
siebengebot gilt dass sie dann unsere
Neigungen
letztendlich abweist das also unsere
individuellen Interessen im Gefühl der
Achtung gegenüber dem moralischen Gesetz
einerlei Bedeutung mehr haben es muss
man natürlich die Achtung genaue
erklären und das sagt auch jetzt kann
gleich später noch erst erklärte aber
was eine Maxime ist er sagt Maxim ist
das subjektive Prinzip des Wollens das
objektive Prinzip das ist dann hingegen
das praktische Gesetz und das praktische
Gesetz wird dann später genauer durch
den kategorischen Imperativ noch erklärt
werden
jetzt erkannt noch was wir haben noch
ein zentrales Zitat wo er sagt dass der
gute Wille das unbedingt die großes
absolute dass das nur mit der
Vorstellung dieses objektiven Gesetzes
zusammenhängen kann das ist das
vorzügliche gute
und die Achtung ist natürlich etwas wage
was meinen kann damit hat eine ganz
lange Fußnote muss nur die Fallen das
sagt man könnte mir vorwerfen als suchte
ich hinter dem Worte achtung nur
Zuflucht ein dunklen Gefühle
sagte obwohl es ein Gefühl ist die
Achtung die moralische Haltung der
Achtung
ist es doch kein durch äußeren Einfluss
empfangenes Gefühl sondern durch einen
Vernunftbegriff selbst gewirkt das
Gefühl von allen anderen Gefühlen die
sie auf Neigung oder Furcht bringen
lassen spezifisch Unterschieden ja also
Achtung ist was ganz besonderes und
Achtung ein mit der Pflicht zusammen in
der Achtung erkennen wir was eigentlich
moralisch geboten ist und wir erkennen
das an und deswegen sagt kann wird in
der Haltung der Achtung unser Egoismus
unsere Selbstliebe eingeschränkt
aber wir sind dem Gesetz unterworfen und
diese Unterwerfung des 7 Gesetzes hat
was mit Furcht aber wir sind zugleich
auch in einem Zustand Erhabenheit wenn
wir erkennen dass wir dadurch eigentlich
erst moralisch handeln wenn wir von
unseren individuellen Eigeninteressen
und ganz unten sagt er das nochmal sehr
klar alles moralisches sogenannte
Interesse besteht lediglich in der
Achtung fürs Gesetz und das Gesetz ist
natürlich dass die autologische Sitten
gesetzt auf dieses Gesetz kommen noch in
einer der nächsten Folge zu sprechen das
ist dann das Sittengesetz was durch den
kategorischen Imperativ genauer
dargestellt wird ja vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit bis zur nächsten Sitzung